hey das hier ist seit einiger zeit meine
begrüßung und ab morgen ist es mehr als
das herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute es ist soweit
morgen um 18 uhr gibt es zum ersten mal
seit vielen jahren menschen da ist
fangen wieder und welche gedanken nicht
mehr gemacht haben dass menschen dass
für dich so gut wie möglich zu machen
möchte die leute erzählen der ein oder
andere mag ist wahrscheinlich schon
wieder manipulation bitter weil ich dich
direkt ansprechen aber ich habe mir
wirklich einige gedanken gemacht und ja
das ganze so persönlich wie möglich zu
machen aber beginnen wir doch einfach
mit dem wichtigsten zuerst uns war mit
dem produkt ja leute was hier an habe es
einst von 250 t shirts wie bereits am
anfang gesagt habe ist ab jetzt mehr als
einfach nur meine begrüßung welche auch
prinzipiell mal ein paar erklärende
worte zu der begrüßung an sich das
eigentlich total simpel uns war ich habe
die hand sagt paul ist klar schon das
sozusagen symbolisieren wie wir
einschlagen so der zuschauer und ich uns
begrüßen und dann geht's los ins video
wie gerade gesagt das einst von 250 t
shirts das heißt wir haben eine sehr
starke limitierung ein paar technische
daten zum t-shirt ist aus 100 prozent
baumwolle dicker als normale t shirts
hatte diesen druck hier vorne den power
dorthin ist ziemlich verschwendet im
siebdruckverfahren aufgesucht also das
hält ewigkeiten das wäsche nicht aus
oder so hinten drin für mich jetzt mal
ein gibt es auch noch ein imprint also
also quasi in label von mir wenn man
überlegt dass wir zum beispiel zu allen
noch laufende oder sowas darzustellen
und als kleiner gag also ja ich sehe das
hier ist einfach ein schillings t shirt
weißes t shirt kann man bleibst du jeder
gelegenheit anziehen so entspannt
geschnitten hat mir gute stoffqualität
tricks unfassbar angenehm das sage ich
jetzt nicht weil es mein t shirt ist
aber ist es einfach echt ultra ultra
chillig und das produkt nummer eins ich
gesagt habe limitierung auf 250 stück
das spiel auch so ein bisschen in diesen
persönlichen aspekt welt ist halt nicht
möglich dass tausend andere leute auf
der welt mit den bedingungen
es gibt haben 250 stück das heißt selbst
bei den video tests mit dem t shirt sehe
sagt er und dann sagen wir machen
nächstes produkt so leute damit sind wir
beim zweiten und auch schon letzten
produkt ihr seht hier an mir der parodie
auch wieder das gleiche logo mit dieser
kuhlen textur in der box im hintergrund
der schriftzug hat so ein richtig
kräftiges gelb und akzent zu setzen
zusätzlich gibt es hier auf dem arm noch
im detail also winter 17 ganz einfach
ist jetzt winter 2017 wäre das wenn das
merchandise floppt auch der ist wieder
mega entspannt er hat 80 prozent war
heute 20 prozent polyester gute kapuze
schilling ist weil ich wäre auch
instagram volk weiß dass sich die
klamotten wirklich seitdem sie haare
durchgehend trocken also ich auch selbst
ich freue mich euch das mädchen das
anbieten zu können und auch hier sind
wieder nur 250 stück also insgesamt 500
artikeln dies zu haben gibt und zwar ab
morgen zählte elfter 18 uhr auf max
closing punkt.de closing klamotten ganz
einfach wird euch natürlich 10.000 mal
in der video beschreibung verlinkt jetzt
muss ich die kamera heran zu dass er
klettert also auch nur noch nicht warum
das video jetzt für dich heißt und warum
das so super persönlich ist klar was
überlegt ihr kennt mich aus dem
digitalen bereich soziale medien habe
mich wahrscheinlich schon öfters in
youtube videos gesehen die aber auch
ganz ganz viele andere leute gesehen
haben mein gedanke den ich hatte weil
ich möchte jeden der mann merchandise
bestellt was persönliches geben und zwar
kriegt jedem stellung ein polaroid dazu
gelegt also ein einzigartiges foto was
ist so auf instagram nicht gab es auf
youtube nicht gab was nur ihr habt ich
habe immer eins rausgezogen keine sorge
das wird dann nicht verschickt weil
sonst wäre ja der effekt kaputt so sieht
das ganze dann aus wie für einen
nachmittag lang mit norman unterwegs und
wir haben viele viele fotos gemacht bis
wir genug hatten das liegt ihr auch mit
nach unterschrift darf das coole als
autogrammkarten weil dann hast du etwas
von mir was du für dich gemacht wurde ja
das ist der gesamte gedanke hinter der
ganzen geschichte ja ich hab ich jetzt
eigentlich alle details zu den artikeln
gesagt noch mal kurz zusammengefasst t
shirt 250 stück bulli 250 t shirt in
weiß mit dem schwarz-weißen problemkind
hinten drin 100 prozent baumwolle wenn
hier der pulli bisschen oversized
geschnitten so für so ein bequem fit den
brustkorb rind mit dem game logo auf der
seite noch als detail winter 17 auf
jeden fall sehr hoch weiter tief
natürlich auch wieder mit im print jetzt
fragte ich sicherlich auch wie viel das
ganze kostet das t shirt wird 27 eur 99
kosten und der poli wird 47 eur 99
kosten ich finde das unfaire preise ich
hoffe ihr auch natürlich kann ich das
nicht so günstig anbieten
wenn ich jetzt 5000 t shirts verkaufen
müsste weit wie ihr vielleicht wisst
wird deshalb bei höherer stückzahl viel
günstiger artikel zu produzieren und
deshalb ist es wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen teurer als bei anderen aber
brauche dass es im rat ja leute war
wirklich aufgeregt vor diesem video weil
es ist auch ein projekt geworden dass
mir ans herz gewachsen ist ich würde
vielleicht dazu noch sagen das merkt
schon dass die youtuber natürlich auch
eine einnahmequelle ist und das ist
natürlich nicht nur zu unserer
identifikation miteinander
gedacht ist sondern dass natürlich auch
ein bisschen was daran verdiene also ja
leute ich hoffe die produkte gefallen
euch morgen 18 uhr max clubbing punkt.de
alle details in der beschreibung ich
kann euch nur empfehlen flott zu sein
und um punkt 18 uhr auf der seite zu
sein ich habe echt jahre lang an war
schon alles gemacht kannst deshalb nicht
genau einschätzen aber es sind halt
wirklich nicht viele produkte und
deshalb genau schaut am besten
rechtzeitig auf der seite vorbei ich
würde mich sehr freuen und bedanke mich
bei jedem von euch fürs zuschauen weil
dir fürs zuschauen und ja dann sehen wir
uns morgen zur normalen video wieder
rasch dann morgen 18 uhr
[Musik]